we have a voicemail number it's to 192
david p and today's voicemail is
actually really timely we talked about
the horrible school shooting yesterday
in parkland Florida and that's sort of
what this voicemail relates to take a
listen David what is a an actual good
response to that annoying thing that
most conservatives say that guns don't
kill people people kill people because I
feel like that is one of the most
vacuous and annoying things I could ever
hear someone say when you're talking
about guns yeah
what is a honestly smart and well
thought out quick response to that that
statement that they love to say yeah
listen your people who actually use that
line because it's such a dumb line
there's probably no one liner that you
can use that's gonna change their mind
right but there's a few a few things
that I keep going back to when people
say guns don't kill people people kill
people yes
people kill people in direct proportion
to the power of the guns that they have
access to and choose to use or misuse
and and it's sort of a it's a
particularly dumb statement because no
object unless you're talking about some
kind of I don't know Rube Goldberg
machine like every object by itself sort
of in a vacuum is not going to kill
people or injure people it's all about
what people do with what we have access
to and as a result we have decided as a
society that devices that can be used to
harm others should be regulated cars
being a good example right cars don't
kill people a car just part is not going
to kill someone unless an out-of-control
skateboarder slams into it headfirst and
and kills themselves on a parked car
right but for the most part we say yeah
the car's not going to kill people it's
the person who using the car driving the
car might kill someone which is why we
need insurance which is why we need a
driver's ed and why we need licensing
and relicensing and whatever else right
it's just not an argument that makes any
sense and sometimes the arguments that
make no sense are the hardest
wants to refute so I don't really have a
one-liner yeah I was gonna say that's
very well said it's a little bit too
elaborate you can't put that on a bumper
sticker oh you got something like you
know yeah people with guns kill people
yeah I did that come back that's
basically what we're saying right which
is yes a people with access to guns are
the ones that are able to kill others I
don't know my advice is if people say to
you guns don't kill people people kill
people with no sense of irony like
sometimes I'll say that on Facebook when
a friend of mine post I'll sarcastically
say but guns don't kill people people
kill people but I'm saying it
satirically if someone says it seriously
to you I wouldn't even bother talking to
them to be perfectly honest and that
phrase also implies that there's always
intent behind a shooting oh yeah
sometimes there is and sometimes these
guns will discharge on their own
sometimes you don't know if it's loaded
or not it's not always intended it's not
so much that they'll discharge on their
own but it's what I call negligent my
Papantonio about that well yeah one of
his one of the lawyers he works with
yeah there are isolated cases where guns
actually like the remington case guns
could fire on their own for the most
part that's what we call being negligent
with your firearms and that should be a
crime right we talk about we have plenty
of rules but we should enforce the ones
we have well yeah how about the one
about going after people whose guns
negligently discharged but we've got a
great bonus show for you today
I'm out of time to tell you what's on it
but it's a good one we'll talk to you
then